What you see over there is
elite modern-day wheat lines
that have a special ability to produce
large amounts of antibiotics
from the root systems.
You may be wondering,
why do we need antibiotics
from the wheat root systems?
You only take antibiotics
when you are sick, isn't it?
The agricultural systems,
the modern farming systems have become
increasingly sick lately.
They are so sick that nearly 70 percent
of the nitrogen fertilizers
that are being applied to farmlands
are being leaked out.
They're leaking nitrogen uncontrollably.
If you look at the nitrogen
fertilizer consumption
from the beginning of
the Green Revolution,
it has grown nearly 30 fold.
From five million metric tons
at the beginning of
the Green Revolution,
to 150 million metric tons,
what we are currently using.
A 30-fold increase in nitrogen
fertilizer consumption
has resulted in a four-fold increase
in global food grain production.
Of course, we all know
that the Green Revolution has transformed
the global food grain production,
saved us from famine,
food scarcities,
and provided the global food security.
But you have to ask yourself.
A 30-fold increase in nitrogen
fertilizer consumption
is supporting only four-fold increase
in food grain production.
What's happening?
When you apply nitrogen fertilizers,
it is mostly in ammonium form.
Ammonium form binds
the soil, doesn't move.
Doesn't create any harmful
nitrogen byproducts.
There's no problem with ammonium nitrogen.
But there is a little bacteria,
lives in the soil,
that started eating away
this fertilizer, nitrogen ammonium,
and spitting it out into nitrate.
And also it's making many other
harmful nitrogen byproducts.
The problem with the nitrates is,
though many plants can use nitrates
as a nitrogen source,
but nitrogen cannot bind to the soil.
It washes out.
If you have rain, if you have irrigation,
it washes out from the farmlands.
That is the problem.
This little bacteria [that]
used to be a small,
subdued microbial activity
in the soil biological activity,
has grown now into a monster.
It's consuming nearly 95 to 99
percent of the fertilizer nitrogen
and splitting it out into nitrates.
We should be asking,
are we fertilizing our crops,
or are we fertilizing this little bacteria
which we have helped to grow
into a big monster?
This is what happens when the nitrogen
moves into water streams,
pollutes lakes,
triggers algal blooms
and creates another Green Revolution.
If you don't keep
the nitrogen in farmlands,
if you allow it to move
into the water bodies,
to the larger ecosystem,
it creates another Green Revolution
in a ecologically destructive way.
If you look at the soil,
it's a living biological system.
An invisible microbial world.
There's a large microbial universe
operating in these soil systems.
They are involved in numerous functions,
breaking down everything
into individual components,
nourishing our crops to grow
and produce food.
It's so complex.
It's much, much bigger
than the ecosystem that we know,
the ecosystem above
the ground that we know.
It's much more complex.
Just to give you an example,
a gram of soil would have
about 10 billion microbial cells.
Ten billion microbes in a gram of soil,
doing various functions.
It's much larger than the entire
human population,
what you see on Earth.
This microbial universe is affected,
affected so severely,
from the last seven decades
of the Green Revolution.
Particularly,
the infusion of large amounts
of nitrogen fertilizers
caused disruption
to this microbial activity
and changed the population dynamics.
As I said, what used to be a small,
insignificant microbial
activity in the soil
has grown into a monstrous proportion,
sucking up all the fertilizer nitrogen
[that] we are applying.
Nature has evolved many solutions
to some of the problems
we are facing in agriculture
and some of the problems
we are going to create
and face in the future.
What you see over there
is a Brachiaria tropical pasture grass.
It grows extensively in South America.
It has a unique ability.
It produces large amounts of antibiotics
from the root systems.
These antibiotics are specifically
directed to this little bacteria,
we say the nitrifying bacteria.
Because of that, it tightly controls
this nitrifying bacteria
function in the soil.
It doesn't allow it to function.
It doesn't kill that bacteria,
but it doesn’t allow it to function,
just [keeps] them in a kind of coma state.
Because of that,
you don't see any kind
of nitrate formation
in these tropical pastures.
In particular,
this tropical pasture grass.
And also, you don’t see any nitrogen gas
emitted from these pastures.
No nitrous oxide is emitted
from these pastures
because it controls
these bacteria so tightly
by producing large amounts of antibiotics
from the root systems.
The question is,
how do we bring this kind of ability
into our crop lands?
Most of our food production
comes from four crops:
Wheat, maize, rice and sorghum.
These are the four crop
that provide the global food security.
Almost 80 to 90 percent of the food grains
are produced from these four crops.
And also ... more than 90 percent
of the entire nitrogen fertilizer
produced industrially
goes to these four production systems.
These food crops, the staple crops,
don't have much ability.
That's the reason they are leaking.
So, if you look at this,
you see the wild wheat.
It has the ability to produce
20 to 30 times antibiotics
from the root systems.
Our group has worked for the last 15 years
to try and locate the genomic region
responsible for producing
these antibiotics
and transfer to the cultivated wheat.
We have done it.
You see that the orange,
orange is here part of the chromosome
that is coming from the wild wheat,
which is coding the antibiotics.
We have got that integrated
to the wheat genome
without disrupting the elite [agronomic]
architecture of the wheat system,
and also without disrupting
the yield potential
and without interfering with
the bread-making quality of the wheat.
This new category of wheats
we call BNI-wheats,
the wheats that can produce
large amounts of antibiotics
from the root systems
to control this bacteria
so that they can control the nitrate
production in the root systems.
Because of this,
the nitrogen fertilizer,
whatever we are applying,
would stay in the
[root-zone], doesn’t leak.
Look at the the BNI wheats,
well, it looks quite healthy and green.
You see the right side,
that is the current modern wheats,
which leaks out all the nitrogen,
whatever we have applied.
Both the plants were applied
the same amount of nitrogen
at exactly the same time.
In one case, it leaked out.
In the other case,
it remained in the farmland.
These are the BNI wheats.
These are the next generation
wheats under development.
So in a few years from now,
they will be available to the farmers.
So our hope is, in the next 10 years,
most of the wheats that are grown
in different parts of the world
would have this kind of ability
so that the nitrogen leakage
can be stopped
by infusing these large
amounts of antibiotics
from the root systems.
That’s what is going to control --
that’s what is going to reduce the amount
of nitrogen fertilizer in future ...
in wheat root systems.
Thank you.
(Applause)